so you mentioned eric davis
eric w davis yes sir
dr eric w davis
what are his comments on your work
from what i know they're not the
congratu
they're not the
positive
that's it so yeah
why do you think that is do you think
because obviously he's an extremely
intelligent person extremely and if he
believed that this was i'm getting a bit
tired so forgive me if i as i that's
quite all right sir i'm i'm i'm getting
there too
this is heavy physics i tell you so yeah
definitely i mean he is in a position to
judge
the veracity of this
yes so i would imagine that he would be
able to see whether it's true or not so
what do you make of him and his
dislogistic comments
i would just say try it experimentally
uh
from what i know um his associate dr
harold putoff has better things to say
about my work
i'll just leave it at that because
there's nothing official on that and
that's hold on sal if you can hear me i
can't see you right now hold on oh boy
sorry sorry so you're saying from what i
know his associate sorry continue that
right from what i know his associate dr
harold put off has a better um
better ideas of my work and
but
that's of a private nature so i cannot
go into that that
the best thing to do is actually go to
dr davis directly and ask him why
why does he think my work is not
worth the paper that's written